the last video here on number five was
all about gaps between prime numbers
specifically
it was about this paper which is a proof
that's just been published
and what it basically says
is no matter how high you go in the
number line no matter how high you count
there is always a pair of numbers still
to come
with a gap of less than 70 million what
that exact number is it doesn't quite
say now 70 million sounds like a really
big number but when you think how big
numbers can get
and how rare prime numbers become as you
get higher and higher it's pretty close
but what's really exciting is that a lot
of people are saying this paper has
taken us a step closer to proving the
twin prime conjecture and what that says
is that there are an infinite number of
prime numbers
separated by just two
so that means no matter how high you
count whether you get to a googleplex or
graham's number or well beyond there is
still an infinite number of prime
numbers ahead of you
that are separated by just two
and when you get that high prime numbers
become incredibly rare so to think that
all these pairings are still out there
it's quite an extraordinary thought now
this proof is 56 pages long and it's
probably beyond most people but we did
make a video about it and i hope you've
watched that already and if you did well
there's a few off takes and a few extra
bits and pieces from that video that we
didn't use that i've now put into this
video so have a watch of that and then
i'll tell you what i think of this paper
at the end
i love it i love it yeah i mean well i
get excited about everything but
but the
i've always loved numbers and uh
i mean just look at the magnitude of the
kind of things
how on earth has someone come up with
that these are the these are the primes
that the the largest
uh twin pair primes and
who knows what the the significance of
these will be i mean i love it just for
the sake of mathematics and the numbers
and i'm full of admiration for people
that can do this
when i was 18 i sort of had the decision
to make whether to do physics or whether
to do mathematics and uh i went the
physics route and i'm very happy i did
but if i'd have gone the mathematics
route this is the kind of thing i would
have loved to do but i'm not sure i'm
good enough so these ones that differ by
two are called are called twin primes
you also get of course ones that differ
by four
okay these are called cousin primes
and there's even those that differ by
six and these are called sexy primes
okay um now in principle it's believed
as well that so it's believed there's an
infinite number of these twin primes
it's believed there's an infinite number
of these cousin prizes believe there's
an infinite number of these sexy primes
in fact it's believed that there is an
infinite number of you know each
possible even gap
between the primes
but it's not been proven so so what we
have here is a pair of primes and they
differ by 2n what um zanger's shown is
that there are an infinite number of
prime numbers
where this difference does not exceed
70 million
there are an infinity of these guys
what's even more remarkable actually
about about the proof that uh the zhang
came up with is that
it didn't actually do anything
completely different right it was really
just application of existing ideas but
just perseverance and that's quite
unusual sometimes when something hasn't
been proven for a very very long time it
really needs some sort of order of
magnitude shift in the way people think
but this what didn't happen here he just
really stuck at it perhaps more than
than others had
um you know and it's it's it's it's a
pretty impressive proof there's no doubt
about here it is 56 pages of it so 70
million it is it's well it's not really
a you know i i was talking about you
know potentially google plexus graham's
number these kind of crazy numbers but
you know
even then there's gaps of only 70
million so it's a tiny number in that
context but actually it's believed of
course it's a lot bigger than two or
four or six here right
it is believed that the methods that uh
zhang used could be optimized even more
and you could get this number down to 16
that's that's that's what's anticipated
here so that would be you know pretty
impressive that there's always gonna if
there's an infinite number of prime
numbers that are separated by only 16
numbers that would be really impressive
but not so they don't reckon he can get
it to turn it's it's not anticipated
that these methods would actually get it
down to two no it's it's 16 is the is
the optimum and it's related to the fact
that the a lot of what zhang did was
based on work of of these guys gold
goldston pins and yielder him
and uh they sort of almost
got there they almost got there what
they proved was um
was that well they had to
well they approved a couple of things
one thing that they proved was that
you so you have this average gap of log
n okay
so that's the average gap of uh of
between prime numbers so exact for
example if n is a googleplex this
average gap is around the googles of
that order anyway
okay so so now the question is you know
so so what what did goldstein pins and
the elderhoom show they showed that you
take any fact fraction any fraction you
want so i take some large n you take any
fraction you want of this gap
and i can prove that the gap between
primes
is less than so i take some fraction let
me call it epsilon
so any
epsilon greater than zero
g p y showed
that there exists so i'm going to show
you a little bit about particle similar
here that there exists okay that means
there exists that backward e so there
exists um prime pairs
separated
by
less than epsilon
log n for large enough n
okay so you might think so what you're
showing it and this is n epsilon okay
this just falls short of proving the
conjecture now why does it just fall
short well in principle i could just
take m bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger if n's finite then you know then
okay that's fine but you know and and n
can be infinite here n can really get
big so so that's not enough because
it just falls short of proving the
conjecture because n n we're talking big
n here and then essentially you want to
tend into infinity ultimately to prove
that there are an infinite number of
these of these pairs
so no matter how you know
okay you can take this fraction to be
arbitrarily small but the thing is
multiplying is getting arbitrarily big
so it's not clear that this that this
um this overall size is actually
getting smaller and smaller it's getting
can stay small can even stay finite it
may even become infinite so they would
fell just short of proven to conjecture
well so
our hero of the day today has also
fallen short of proving the big
conjecture no but he i mean he at least
proved that there was a finite gap but
ultimately there is a finite gap you
know and there's an infinite number of
these guys with a finite gap so what gpy
did show and this is where this 16 comes
in
is they showed that if something called
the the elliott halberstam conjecture is
true
and we don't know it's true it's
expected to be true but they don't know
it's true
then there are an infinite number of
prime numbers
which differ by less than 16. so this is
where the 16 comes in just to go back to
our hero of today
what is it about his proof that makes 70
million fall out it seems such an
obvious number and yet it's such a
perfect round number okay so
um so how does how when people do number
theory how do they actually go about
doing these proofs they they tend to use
sea of theory now the simplest uh
version of a sieve theory is is by uh
comes back from ancient greece a guy
called aristophanes he he wanted to work
out what all the primes were so he began
by just writing out all the numbers so
yeah you begin he begins with two
because you know one isn't going to be
one's not defined as a prime so you
begin with two
three
four and i'll do 31 and 32. okay and it
goes on and on of course and what he
said was you begin at two
so you that's going to be your first
number and you now cross out
every number that's divisible by 2. why
because that can't be a prime
because thank you a prime is defined as
a number that's divisible only by itself
um or
possibly by one but but one doesn't
count usually so we begin with two so
four of course all the even numbers now
immediately you wipe out i'm sieving
they're falling through the sieve right
that's exactly what's going on and so
i've got rid of them so now you move to
three which is the next one by itself
and you do the same three well
six already has been ruled out
but nine goes 12 has already gone 15
goes 27 goes 30 is gone
four is already gone
five is the next one okay and you know
so then you start going through ten as
so anything divisible by five is uh
removed so 10 is already gone 15's
already gone 20 is already gone 25 has
hasn't gone yet but has now what you're
now left with actually are all the
primes if i just label the ones that are
left you've got 11
19. 23
29 31 i've got all the primes up to 31
and this is the technique that you can
use to actually save out the primes this
would give me all the primes right if i
had enough computing power and enough
time and i could do it faster i would
get all the primes just by writing out
this series and just doing it and it
will infinite in all infinity and all
infinity of it take me a long long time
an infinite amount of time
but i could do it
infinite amount of time yeah
so we haven't got that and the funding
agencies won't allow won't fund us for
that kind of
time we've got another 26 minutes so
what what
so what is what people have done is
they've they've refined this sieve
they've in such a way that it's not as
uh accurate as this
so maybe you think it's a bit more
coarse-grained save and so more things
um will
will fall through but what you are left
with are
that rather than having these fine
primes immediately left what you're left
with the groups of numbers with which
you
improve your chances of finding the
primes so you have some idea of the kind
of values of numbers you you're looking
for you develop your sieve accordingly
and then all the other stuff comes
through and you're left with this range
of numbers within which you hope you're
going to find these big primes just look
at the sizes that we're kind of talking
about
and so
this these modified sieves are used by
um mathematicians to try and establish
these bounded sets
and that's basically
and the work of zhang has been based on
some earlier work by a group of
mathematicians who showed that it's who
almost got there to find to find this uh
and this bound but couldn't quite make
it and he what he did is he basically
modified the sieve that he was using
which meant he had just a slightly
different way of of getting the these
the bigger prime numbers and from it he
was able to demonstrate that indeed
there is a bound and
just based on the type of sieve he was
using um this bound turned out to be 70
million that he came up with so 70
million is an artifact of the sieve that
he yeah
yeah
there are two technique two thing
there's a sieve and then there's a
something which i just can't get my head
around called the level of distribution
which tells you how the how the prime
numbers how regular they become when
you're looking on on
very large for very large values
and uh
so it was this combination that he used
and and out of it which no one else had
been had been able to do and there is a
nice sort of
um
uh aspect to this story which is a
um he's over 50. okay no one knew about
him he works at the university of new
hampshire he'd obviously been working
away
um
he's which means you can do great maths
over 50 you're not totally burnt out
and
b that the um
he wasn't he came up with some
phenomenally new breakthrough he just
kept plugging away at the techniques
people had been doing and just by doing
that was able to modify them
sufficiently to make this and and it's
been
he sent it to the journal in april
and the journal
editor to their credit i mean they must
get mathematics journals must be
inundated with people saying they've
solved these problems because the
problems are so easy to say right
there's an infinite number of primes who
differ by two
i bet there's i i remember trying to
prove this at school thinking that can't
be that difficult the number five inbox
is inundated with people claiming i'm
sure
so the to their credit the editors of
the journal realized this guy knew what
he was talking about apparently the
paper was beautifully written crystal
clear
and they fast-tracked it through the the
refereeing process they and they must
have some way of putting on a conveyor
belt that sends it to the referees who
all unanimously said this this is
potentially really important i i i scan
the proof and then i but i went online
and and found
some really nice um sort of explanations
from because because one thing that um
that happened is so he he gave a talk at
harvard
and it was extremely well received and
they feel very excited about it and
there's people coming because everybody
loves prime numbers right so there are
people coming from different fields to
see this talk and then but what people
have done is some people who are out
that talk i put some really nice sort of
explanations online of what of the proof
involved and and so so those are i find
particularly useful because they were
they were coming from people who weren't
they were written by people who weren't
normal theorists but and i'm not a
normal theory so that that was very
useful to me but incidentally there's a
a nice little sort of quirk of faith
uh
which which happened when while that
talk was going on in that a paper came
online while that talk was going on
which actually proved another one of
these sort of crazy conjectures and it
was the gold back conjecture or at least
a um a weakened version of the goldberg
conjecture which says so the original
goldbach conjecture which is one of the
great problems of of of mathematics it's
one of the uh you know it's one of these
millennium you get one of these
millennium prizes if you if you solve it
um is that every even to prove that
every even number can be written as the
sum of two primes
okay so the weakened version that this
guy proved that the it came out while
zhang was given his talk was that um
every odd
number
greater than five
can be written as the sum of three
primes so he proved it's a slightly
weakened version of the original
conjecture and um
so it's kind of there's been sort of two
really big events within number theory
sort of coming together at the same time
and you know the the the implications
for this uh in terms of
now that there's new ideas coming in
there's even hope that maybe one could
solve the the riemann hypothesis
which is
so the the riemann hypothesis states
that there's a particular function
called the riemann function which i can
write down quite straightforwardly it
has the form
zeta of z is
is there the sum
over n of one over n to the z
okay the riemann hypothesis asks where
are the zeros of this function
okay and um
it seems
what he says is is that they all lie so
in the complex plane we're thinking
where are they in the complex plane they
all lie on the line with real number a
half
not obvious it's a hypothesis
great minds have failed to prove this
time and time and time again and
one thing that um
that is hoped is that we now might be
progress to solving to proving this so
you know all these things together this
kind of hope there's going to be real
progress now incidentally we use this
this riemann zeta function in quantum
field theory as well so this has
applications sort of beyond just number
theory
i mean you're a physicist not a
mathematician does this excite you when
you read about this and see this i think
everybody everybody loves prime numbers
don't they i think i think you know you
can't fail to love prime numbers you
know
i think the the the great thing i was
thinking about this um because i knew
you'd ask me that really
i think the thing about prime numbers
that that i think fascinates
anybody who's interested in maths
physics that kind of thing is that they
seemingly lack some sort of structure
they seem to everything that we we like
to think that we understand nature that
things
ultimately will adhere to some sort of
structure and that we can make sense of
that thus far
prime numbers seem to sort of evade that
possibility they seem to just be so
higgledy piggledy where what is the
structure that underpins prime numbers
and these sort of conjectures are sort
of going some way towards giving prime
numbers this really
these these these elusive things that be
that they're really refusing or so thus
far refused to sort of you know come
under the grip of our uh of uh are
trying to make sense of them and to
apply structure to them
these sort of conjectures and proving
them is heading some way to to doing
that and that's why it's sort of like
you know is it almost the final frontier
of our understanding in some way we're
making sense of something that's su so
everybody can understand what three is a
prime number or five is a prime number
you know and it's something that's so
sort of familiar to us and yet seemingly
we understand so little about
i guess that's the fascination do you
know what else the prime number is 19
19. stuart downing
oh yeah yeah he's had a good second half
of caesars do it down and actually good
signing
i i don't want to say definitely yeah
he had a good second half of season i
will say that and he's so he's falls
improved
so this paper by yetang zhang which is
by all accounts an extraordinary piece
of work it's well beyond
my my capabilities but i did note it's
56 pages long and i think the
typesetters have missed an opportunity
here if they kind of just
made the points i was a bit bigger or
put a bit more spacing in there they
could have got up to 59 pages and that's
a twin prime
you know that's what i would have done